[Musique]
chantal hébert michel david stéphanie
grammond bonsoir bonsoir
donc j'en parlais plus tôt un appareil
beaucoup dans l'émission je veux avoir
votre analyse je vous faire entendre
ceux qui n'étaient pas avec nous à tout
début d'émission que vous allez me dire
ce que vous en pensez
les différents la différence entre cette
citoyenne qui est pas contente où ils
servent et les menaces là on est dans
deux mondes différents et joe faire
entendre surtout quand les opposants
monsieur deuxième dit il veut amener la
grogne l'assemblée nationale ça vient
d'où sauver sa vie d'une déclaration
qu'il a faite que je vais vous faire
entendre qu'on vient après pour parler
tout sa
jeunesse citoyens avec ce n'est donc je
vais devoir
revoir
notre objectif c'était justement de
prendre toute cette grogne qui étaient à
l'extérieur du parlement puis de la
faire entrer dans les murs du parlement
qui cite encore sur notre objectif pour
le 3 octobre prochain
on veut pas de grumeaux par la main et
si votre legs démocratique cela veut
dire que vous allez canaliser la haine
la colère c'est un très mauvais langues
démocratique peut être reconsidérer la
raison comme le faire votre entrée au
parlement
il faut prendre cette grande gueule ou
appelez ça comme vous ce sentiment
d'exclusion dont une partie de la
population
qu'une porte la population récent il
faut transformer ça en espoirs et ses
seuls partis conservateurs du québec moi
ce que je veux c'est que ces gens là ne
se sentent pas exclu qu'ils ne sentent
pas que leurs institutions démocratiques
ne les représentent pas une pâle pas
pour elle je veux que ces personnes
aient l'impression qu'elles peuvent
avoir une place autour de la table où se
prennent les décisions à l'assemblée
nationale du québec
alors que ces gens là donc dit-il plein
et il est une voix à l'assemblée
nationale chantal hébert qu'est ce que
vous pensez de la lure du débat depuis
deux jours
je pense beaucoup de bien parce qu'on en
parle et on en parle de toutes sortes de
façons d'autre part je pense aussi
beaucoup de bien de l'idée que les gens
qui se sentent exclus du système trouve
une bois l'assemblée nationale il me
semble que c'est plus 5 de dire on veut
pas les entendre et on ne veut pas à
l'assemblée nationale cela dit j'ai
regardé comme la plupart d'entre nous
les 15 secondes ou françois legault
didier il faut des dépôts plus serein ce
qui m'a surtout frappé c'est toutes les
réactions qu'elle vit en dessous
c'était vraiment particulier dans le
sens négatif du monde ouais dès qu'on
touche à ça les commentaires bonne
chance michel davy du premier run
première réaction ben moi c'est
l'expression que de monsieur duhaime
canaliser le mécontentement à tout ça ça
me laisse un peu perplexe dans la mesure
où tu te fais d'accord mieux vous que le
mécontentement s'exprime à l'assemblée
nationale plutôt que dans la rue tout le
monde est d'accord là dessus mais
canaliser qu'est ce que ça veut dire
est-ce que c'est canaliser au profit de
monsieur duhaime parce que des fois on a
l'impression que oui tout en voulant
représenter les gens ils alimentent
aussi la grogne il veut pas juste le la
refléter et là il
comme souvent monsieur duhaime est très
habile et il comment dire
il est chaud tout en douceur alors que
dans le fond il mort
alors je me suis dit je suis tout à fait
d'accord ces gens là ont le droit d'être
représentés à l'assemblée nationale mais
la façon dont monsieur duhaime se
comporte on a très souvent l'impression
que il veut aussi accroître le
mécontentement des gens et ne pas
peut-être
déplaire à des gens vraiment en colère
qui ne voudrait pas entendre leur chef
dénoncé ceci ou cela stéphanie grammond
j'en ai tout fait mais je renchérirait
sur ce que michel disent je pense
qu'effectivement un monsieur duhaime est
un très habile communicateur et quand il
s'adresse à l'ensemble de la population
comme il le fait au lancement de sa
campagne il dit des choses que tout le
monde veut entendre qui paraît stressant
c'est qu'ils sont et
est donc ça s'appelait à la majorité
mais en même temps un sous texte il
s'adresse aussi aux franges de la
population qui peut-être justement où il
ya plus de hann de colère de grogne il
ya des sondages qui montrent que la
moitié de ces de ses partisans des gens
qui pensent voter pour le parti
conservateur
haddad et à des thèses du complot
quand on regarde aussi du côté des
candidats qui qui met de l'avant mais il
y en a qui il y en a qui ont eu des
propos assez
assez alarmant il y en eut une cube
finalement qui s'est retiré mais elle
avait dit il y en a plusieurs qui
devrait se faire tirer la pomme bill
gates et puis ça clique de mondialiste
donc là on est vraiment des dents de
l'incitation à la haine il y en a un
autre que des plus le candidat dans
joliette qui a comparé
le gouvernement de monsieur leubou à
vladimir poutine puis akin jaune parce
qu'évidemment il déplorait le la façon
dont on a géré la pandémie moi je pense
que s'il ya neuf ans un stage russie ou
peut-être en corée du nord il verra de
quel bois en ont chauffé les opposants
politiques il se rendra compte que c'est
un petit peu différent you la pandémie
il ya beaucoup la pandémie qui explique
que c'est comme si beaucoup de gens
on
il se sentait libéré de toute parole
alain rey est ce plus tôt cette semaine
député fédéral conservateur qui dit j'en
peux plus dès que j'en vois quelque
chose sur les réseaux sociaux on se fait
insulter
alors il dit moi là je vais bloqué bloc
est bloqué il ya un contexte plus
général les journalistes qui sont prises
à partie monsieur trudeau a aussi parlé
de ça ça tient à peu près au même
phénomène on l'écouté c'était
aujourd'hui
c'est un vrai problème et ça commence
avec l'idée que tous les politiciens
doivent être unanimes dans leur
condamnation de l'intimidation et la
violence contre ceux qui font le travail
que ce soit d'autres politiciens ou que
ce soit des journalistes nous devons de
démontrer du leadership responsable qui
dit c'est pas ça le pays la démocratie
qu'on est en train de bâtir ensemble
et bien malin chantal celui qui pourrait
prédire vers où on s'en va ce que ça va
se durcir encore tous ces commentaires
publics cette confrontation
cette polarisation
bon d'abord pendant justin trudeau on
peut être d'accord avec son message et
sa voix aussi que c'est un message
intéressé parce que c'est un message qui
vise qui pierre poignet moi j'ai regardé
cette semaine des vidéos ou bien
poilievre soit 2 ovation debout pour
avoir dénoncé le forum économique
mondial
donc pour donner les théories de
conclure chercher plus loin qui ont tué
mais vous allez trouver terre poilievre
est très semblable mais beaucoup de
chances que ce soit le prochain chef de
l'opposition officielle à ottawa
ou escales ras voix se situer dans ce
parti là où est ce que beaucoup de
députés conservateurs vont se situer
point d'interrogation mais l'idée que ça
va disparaître parce que monsieur
legault fait un message de 15 secondes
où tous les chefs y compris et du md il
faut pas faire ça non c'est pas là que
ça semble on est on est en plein dedans
jusqu'aux dents comme dirait cher le bon
on est vraiment en plein dedans et
poilievre qui a il s'est fait tirer
l'oreille finalement il a dit il a
dénoncé l' attaque contre chris tiers
freeland parce que on l'avait mis
presque dans un coin maison qui apporte
que pas envoyé beaucoup de messages de
cas non plus lui
x 10 ne veut pas décevoir certaines
bases qui le regarde comme un comme un
dieu et michel a tout à fait monsieur
poilievre c'est un peu le même phénomène
que maître du jamais vu une puissance
à ses supérieurs
et tous ces gens là vont être alimentée
par les transformations qui vont venir
là il a eu la pandémie lyon tous on
s'entend tous pour dire que ça a été un
catalyseur de mécontentement mais au
cours des années à venir vous savez les
sacrifices qui vont et exiger des gens
pour lutter contre les changements
climatiques
ça va engendrer beaucoup beaucoup de
frustration et ça va amplifier je pense
le mécontentement à tous les niveaux de
la société et les policiers je pense que
ne sont pas en mesure actuellement de
ont pas la solution et je prétends pas
d'avoir non plus non il faut s'attendre
à ce que ça s'aggrave
oui comme si on il y aura des sacrifices
a demandé puis on pas sauvé us en france
et 8 heures de show
il ya 50 pour sa part prenons le québec
à 50% où on a un plan détaillé pour la
réduction des gaz à effet de serre pour
les entreprises et un autre 50 % qui est
inexistant c'est les citoyens sont alors
à des mauvaises de même actuellement les
policiers sont pas prêts à affronter ça
par exemple dans le plan de lutte contre
les changements climatiques de q s on ne
veut pas forcer de spéculer on ne veut
pas forcer la main de personne encore
aucun parti politique ne propose d'aider
des mesures qui vont faire mal ouais
c'est fanny c'est intéressant ce que tu
me cherches le parallèle avec des
discours qui seront pas populaires qui
devront venir à mende les capitales si
on veut régler enfin si on peut apaiser
cette crise puis l'ancien ministre de
l'environnement le du côté fédéral dit
aussi qu'elle ait eu sa dose le
d'intimidation le traité de barbie de
l'environnement de tous les noms moi ce
que je trouve extrêmement préoccupant
dans ces menaces là et qui sont de plus
en plus présente dans les médias sociaux
mais aussi sur le terrain les vaches
c'est que
évidemment ça donne pas le goût à
personne ne se lance en politique ni de
prendre position dans l'arène publique
mais en particulier les femmes on
voudrait qu'elle soit plus nombreuses en
politique mais sont aussi quand même
beaucoup la cid de des gens qui est
comme ça font des menaces donc c'est pas
une façon
d'attirer des gens en politique il va
rester à peu près juste les gens qui
sont extrêmement agressifs les autres
qui sont plus modérées vont se dire ah
ben moi je veux être je peux être dans
les médias sociaux je dois être dans je
dois être dans les échanges publics
parce que j'ai pas envie -2 2 me
retrouver avec ce genre de commentaires
noah
avec lesquels il faut que je dorme le
soir oui oui elle est restée particulier
cette semaine parce qu'on se dira t il y
en a vu d'autres et tout ça c'est que ça
dépasse ceux qui sont sur les réseaux
sociaux le voit le constate ça dépasse
ce qu'on avait déjà connu autre sujet
annonçant santé c'est un sujet qui
préoccupe les gens dans tous les
sondages
c'est pas mal numéro 1 au numéro deux
avec le coût de la vie annonce pour
écouter monsieur legault qui reconnaît
qu'il faut trouver des nouveaux médecins
660 dit il mais ça se voit pas comme ça
et après geoffrey vont venir après
monsieur le groupe je ferai entendre
monsieur trudeau pas ce que je vais vous
demander le rapport de force pour aller
on august dossier l'homme est allé
chercher de l'argent à ottawa qu'en
est-il mon écoute monsieur logo d'abord
le plus gros défi c'est trouver du
personnel puis l'on peut pas faire de
magie ça prend un certain nombre
d'années former du personnel n'est on
s'engage si on était réélu le 3 octobre
prochain a ajouté 1 400 millions de
dollars pour une série de mesures pour
augmenter
le personnel nombre de personnes
s'assoient des médecins que ce soit des
infirmières ou d'autres personnels
tour de table rabais de la tue le défi
est tous partis confondus lors de cette
campagne au québec c'est d'être crue sur
cette question des médecins stéphanie
absolument et puis je pense que
et évidemment tous les partis vont se
positionner vont nous faire des
promesses je crois que il faut faire
attention parce que les belles promesses
on sait que ça pue retombe et à plat il
ya des problèmes qui sont plus faciles à
tenir que d'autres en santé comme la iv
qui avait promis de rendre le
stationnement gratuit pour les deux
premières salles et dans les airs giteau
ça se fait bien bravo mais de dire tout
le monde va avoir un médecin à un
médecin de famille on sait qu'il ya
encore plus de 800 mille de personnes
québécois qui en ont pas on est loin du
compte depuis les libéraux nous
permettent encore la même chose mais en
mieux saisir une maison qu'on peut être
un peu désabusé et maintenant à propos
des mets fins et on va informer
davantage absolument ce une bonne idée
mais moi pour avoir posé souvent la
question pourquoi on n'enferme pas plus
la réponse est dans les hôpitaux il faut
qu'on leur qu'on leur donne des stages à
ces médecins et leur parce que c'est pas
juste sur les bancs d'école qu'on
apprend à devenir docteur et les places
sont limitées
on a eu des fils de ce côté là je viens
de voir comment vos souffrances pas
juste une question d'argent mais aussi
une question d'organisation
en effet c'est pas juste une question
d'argent mais il ya aussi une question
d'argent qui je vous lance tout de suite
michel et chantal sur l'autre est super
on va écouter monsieur trudeau qui je
voue l'un sur l'autre aspect est ce
qu'il ya encore un pouvoir d'abord ce
qui est encore un unanimité du côté des
provinces pour demander à ottawa
quel est le rapport de force actuel vous
avez ottawa on écoute ce trou d'eau on
sait très bien que c'est pas juste une
question de plus d'argent il faut qu'on
ait les résultats pour les canadiens
les résultats concrets pour les
québécois et c'est les conversations
qu'on est en train d'avoir il ya trop de
gens qui n'ont pas de médecin de famille
trop de gens qui attendent trop
longtemps pour avoir mes services de
santé mentale nous allons être là avec
des investissements de plus mais nous
devons pouvoir rassurer tous les
canadiens que tous les investissements
que ce soit provinciales ou fédérales
vont livrer de vrais résultats de vraies
améliorations dans les systèmes de santé
donc éventuellement des indicateurs en
tout cas on verra mais rapport de force
chantal on a vu la liberté hier je
pensais hier ou avant-hier annoncé des
lits des records de compte tenu du prix
du pétrole les raisons sont sortis du
rouge
sang sont 7 au
12 milliards de 12 à 13 milliards de
surplus exact j'appelle pas ça sentir
dans le noir
la pression c'est 500 ils en ont
effectivement 22 fois plus donc où on en
est dans ce dossier là chantal
c'est sûr que vu de tower sur le front
de la négociation en santé on regarde la
campagne électorale et en sus
extraordinaire parce que l'impression
qu'on a depuis une semaine c'est qu'on
agisse en argent ici il y en a tellement
que on peut faire des baisses dépôt où
on peut envoyer de l'argent à gauche et
à droite et c'est une bataille d'opinion
publique on peut argumenter sur le
principe de la participation fédérale au
programme par rapport à ce que c'était
dans passé mais dans les faits quand
deux premiers ministres en voir les
mêmes ses lecteurs et 10 j'ai besoin de
plus d'argent et l'autre il y en a pas
mal puisque il vient d'annoncer 56000
baisses d'impôts à court terme devinez
qui bannissent des ballons je note aussi
l'amitié particulièrement cultiver de
monsieur trudeau avec monsieur ford
pendant qu'on est occupé ailleurs au
québec et je me dis c'est pas des heures
père vu qu'on parle christophe willem
dominic leblanc ce qu'on est en train de
faire du côté d'ottawa pendant la
campagne au québec ses impôts brisé mais
un peu effrité la course en ontario a pu
s'attendre les quotas rios discrètement
ont fait michel oui bon les frais du
front commun des provinces on sait on a
vu dans le passé je pense qu'on peut pas
suffire là dessus cette fois ci mais il
est passé à 5 d'autre chose ou si
souvenez vous je pense que c'est en 2007
monsieur charest premier ministre du
québec à ottawa c'est monsieur rappeur
monsieur charest s'en vend d'élections
supplie monsieur harper de lui 2 et de
l'argent parce que dit il le système de
santé en un besoin cruel qu'est ce que
monsieur charest fait un coup que le
chèque est arrivé annonce des baisses
d'impôts monsieur harper a compris la
leçon ayant gelé les les transferts ou
le transfert canadien en santé monsieur
trudeau et pas plus fou comme ce rapport
il regarde ce qui se passe ils voient
les surplus ils voient que les provinces
on nage dans le noir ou à des niveaux
différents mais même au québec a dès
l'an prochain on a des surplus
york est ce qu on fait avec on donne des
airs on baisse les impôts alors
d'autre part le rapport de forces c'est
aussi la population et je pense que les
au québec et probablement dans le reste
du canada quand les gens voient l'état
de leur salle de leur système de santé
ils se disent post eu ce que c'est une
mauvaise affaire qu'ottawa vient de
mettre un peu d'ordre là-dedans regarder
ce qu'on fait là nous
nos dirigeants au niveau des provinces
alors monsieur trudeau et poje en
déficit de d'appui dans la population
dans ce dossier là très bien alors
messieurs dames on se retrouve très
bientôt merci beaucoup pour ce panel
encore une fois au revoir avant en bon